on passe maintenant aux rebondissements
de la terre mesrine avec lucien aimé
blanc
lucien et de l'entente soit rejoint donc
vous publié chez plon un livre qui
s'appelle la chasse à l'homme la vérité
sur la mort de mesrine essais signés
dont commissaire divisionnaire lucien
aimé blanc c'est vous vous tenez à
marseille en 1935 votre père est mort à
dachau vous avez été nommé commissaire
en 1962 en 1966 vous prenez la direction
la brigade antigang
en 74 la direction de la brigade des
stups les gares de marseille pour
démontrer la french connection voilà et
en 1977 vous devenez fou commissaire
divisionnaire à le servait voilà est
donc en 79 quand mesrine est abattu vous
êtes à la tête de l'eau crb voilà donc
le chien mais blanc vous publie la
chasse à l'homme que vous avez créé en
collaboration avec un ex de libé jean
michel caradec 1
alors ça se lit comme un polar de la
série noire se rend passionnant votre
bouquin je conseille vraiment à tout le
monde quand ça commence vous couvrez un
casse ça c'est incroyable de voir un
grand flic comme ça qui prouve un casse
lucien aimé blanc est en train de
surveiller pendant toute une nuit une
propriété dans laquelle des truands sont
en train de dérober des immeubles de
valeur et vivres escorté jusqu'à 100 km
de paris et vous les laisser partir et
que le butin à l'époque elle était
complètement dans le vent malgré une
coordination malgré la mobilisation des
services de police mais ce qu'ils ne
savaient pas où ils étaient fallait le
retrouver donc grâce à des informateurs
j'ai réussi à retrouver sa piste et de
ses informateurs il fallait les payer
oui c'est henri leblanc qui vous avez
aidé à retrouver un power donc il
fallait le pays le ministère veut pas
fini de pognon on l'avait les termes
j'ai la cheville dans mon bouquin le
ministère l'a dit aimé blanc les
fonctionnaires ont beaucoup de travail
et leur foi de frais de mission les 3
millions seront affectés
vous avez la gloire vous ne rêviez
légion d'honneur ni l'argent bon il
fallait que je me débrouille pour payer
ses informateurs parce que si c'est fait
arrêter sur ce casque parce que ce cas
ci l'aurait fait quand même
mais puisque c'étaient des
professionnels il n'avait pas besoin de
moi pour faire ses classes mais en
vérité un petit commissariat côté qui
pouvait les gêner
et moi j'ai pensé que si je faisais
arrêter un il avait expliqué toute
l'histoire oui et là c'était une bombe
qu'il me serais retrouvé sur donc voilà
c'est bien ce que je disais le bouquin
commencer vous surveiller un case le
regarder en assume complètement voilà
mais bien entendu leur inscription
maintenant je pense qu'ils ont ils n'ont
pas cassé importe si c'est une bonne
nouvelle
dites moi à l'époque tous les moyens
étaient bons pour venir à bout de
mesrine dont même les 10 les plus les
plus malsains parce que c'est l'époque
où vraiment à la fin mesrine était
devenu un mythe d'un personnage de
légende vous raconter ça très bien
d'ailleurs
et justement c'est un type robin des
bois mesrine ils étaient censés voler
aux riches pour donner aux pauvres
oui mesrine si vous voulez avec ses
complices se jouait un peu belge cassidy
et le kid
il faisait plainte fait d'armes il s'est
fait arrêter en 73 il s'évade en prenant
en otage le président du tribunal quand
broussard l'art est il offre le
champagnes publie l'instinct de mort qui
son autobiographie ça aussi ça me fait
mal partant durant il a un procès en 77
qui est un véritable événement mondain
il jette les clés de sa cellule au
président du tribunal en disant voilà
dans votre prison tout s'achète
violent quoi il est condamné à 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle mais il s'évade de
la santé c'est quand même pas facile ils
braquent le casino de lille ils bravent
la société générale reims il donne
l'interview à match
ils kidnappent l'industriel lelièvre et
puis là effectivement il commence à
politiser son discours d'hier dont j +
hs bien sûr et puis c'était au moment de
la loi fameuse loi peyrefitte sécurité
et liberté liberté c'était une loi de
rigolade deux garçons demain à côté de
celle de sarkozy dire oui mais je suis
pas si c'est pas des effets d'annoncé
aujourd'hui ce qu'on entend enfin le
sort et la tension ça m'intéresse plus
oui beaucoup
il aimait beaucoup les femmes un mesrine
je crois qu'il est je ne sais pas s'il
aimait les femmes plusieurs femmes mais
il a toujours eu des femmes qui étaient
devenus sle ses complices et qui n'ont
jamais trahi c'est ce que je dis bon il
avait quelques équipes il fallait de
l'équipe il est temps en temps mais il
avait une seule qualité l'acquis de
excusez moi l'expression on est mouillé
jamais cette femme ne faisait pas avoir
accueilli les faisait pas la femme
c'était le repos du guerrier si j'en
deviens comme tout le monde il vous fait
rêver mesrine mais c'est 90 ou plutôt
symbolique c'est un bassin me rappelle
une chanson de truste d'ailleurs way sur
les qhs sur les choses comme ça à bord
avants 16
l'essai
une chanson de truste toujours parole de
mesrine s'appelle le mitard oui vous
connaissiez ça oui le mitard aussi oui
oui alors c'est un peu comme dans les
films à ce moment là la hiérarchie
s'impatiente un c'est un peu comme on
voit matignon voix l'elysée on voit le
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
beaudoin monsieur giscard d'estaing
s'impatiente et terriblement
et puis le 2 novembre 1979
l'appartement de mesrine et où il vit
avec sylvia et le jeanjacquot et
localiser ces rue belliard donc et un
jour il sort de cet appartement
la scène est célèbre dans une bmw 528
qui est bloquée place de clignancourt
par une fourgonnette bleue bâché d'où
quatre tireurs de l'antigang ouvre le
feu avec des carabines automatique et un
pistolet mitrailleur 19 blessures
mortelles pour mesrine et sa compagne
sylvia jeanjacquot grièvement blessés
voilà ça c'est la version 10 ont connu
des faits assure officiel en fait si
vous voulez je n'étais pas plus
responsable cette opération comme je
l'expliqué dans le bouquin puisque
monsieur goussard commandait la berri et
été compétence eau paris ouais moi
j'avais le crb bon c'était l'organisme
au niveau national et donc des comptes
intervenait ce soit à paris soit à
marseille on était obligés d'être en
assistance avec le service compétent
donc broussard était compétent le
directeur bien sûr tout tout à fait à
des idées chez vous ça pour conduire
cette opération en me disant écoutez
mais blanc compte tenu du travail et des
risques que vous avez pris dans des
manipulations un peu spécial
il dit plus tard qu'elles seront
malsaine était bien content de les
habits peu sage
alors donc monsieur broussard et chargée
de cette opération et c'est lui qui est
entièrement responsable voit la
coopération alors voilà donc mesrine est
abattu mort d'une star pratiquement
direct les policiers exulte devant
l'objectif des photographes
le ministre bonnet le président giscard
d'estaing sont effectivement satisfait
mais dès le lendemain la polémique est
lancée
ce que vous appelez passe de 129 de
votre livre la machine à fabriquer du
doute se met en marche
parce qu'effectivement si ya pas eu de
sommation c'est un assassinat
vous allez me poser la question de
savoir s'il ya eu des sommations voilà
la famille porte plainte
schématiquement immédiatement et
effectivement mesrine d'après ce qu'on
en sait en tous les cas ils étaient
assez calmes au volant de sa bmw et
sylvia jeanjacquot a déclaré quand la
bâche du camion s'est soulevé les hommes
armés étaient déjà en position et ils
ont tiré tout de suite ils ont pas fait
de sommations et alors le commissaire
broussard c'est là on en vient aux
points importants du livre de lucien
aimé-blanc le commissaire broussard un
peu le patron de l'anti gang qui a battu
mesrine donc n'a jamais varié lui l'a
toujours